If I showed you Terrance Malick’s most recent
film, Song to Song, along side his debut film
Badlands shot 44 years earlier, they would
seem dramatically different.
Much of what seems to make up the look and
feel of Malick's newer work is the unique
cinematography developed in collaboration
with Emmanuel Lubezeki Malick’s Director
of Photography since The New World.
The free-flowing cinematography fits the non-traditional
approach to narrative.
And it’s one of the most interesting, most
expressive uses of wide angle lenses I’ve
seen in film.
But if we look closely at Badlands an everything
that follows, we’ll find many clues that
will help us uncover what motivates the stories
Malick chooses to tell and how he chooses
to tell them.
The directors before series is sponsored by
MUBI.
Go to MUBI.com/thomasflight to get your free
trial today.
Badlands is an impressive debut film.
Malick has a clear artistic vision from the
very start.
Loosely based on real event, Badlands tells
the story of 25 year old Kit’s killing spree
and 15 year old Holly as she unquestioningly
accompanies him.
From the very beginning we can see a unique
approach to story forming.
I think perhaps the most significant element
of Malick’s style is his focus on the interior
landscape of the characters.
His films concern themselves with what the
character’s are thinking and feeling, this
comes before any consideration of specific
plot details.
I think his entire approach to filmmaking
is structured around communicating that internal
landscape.
One of the tools he uses to do that, one that
features as an important part of Badlands
and every one of his subsequent films
is Voiceover.
While use of voiceover in film is often criticized
as a crutch for bad writing, Malick’s use
of voiceover serves to accompany, more than
to re-state plot.
Character’s are often musing or observing.
And you get the feeling that the voice over
is almost more for the character rather than
it is for the audience.
Malick’s approach to voiceover is similar
to his approach to cinematography, it’s
there to observe, not to construct.
This interior landscape is naturally subjective
and it’s reinforced by the perspective of
the narrative.
Malick stays with the characters that the
story focuses on, rarely zooming out to a
broader perspective to inform the audience.
The audience gets to know what the characters
know or care about and do, not much more.
You’re there with them.
And rarely do we even get a wide shot or an
establishing shot to ground the character
within the world.
Rather the focus is on the character’s subjective
experience of the environment around them.
The one time in Badlands where we do get a
birds eye view perspective of what’s happening
away from the protagonists, it’s cast in
an oddly stylized black and white montage,
almost as if we’re seeing from Holly’s
perspective in the future, how she imagined
things happened.
And this subjectivity, is I think what leads
to Malick’s emphasis on nature and environment
as a part of the storytelling.
This will become a much heavier focus and
play a larger role in later films, but it’s
very present in Badlands.
The films title itself speaks to this approach
to filmmaking.
After the character experience, the environment
is the next focus, again taking priority over
plot and narrative.
The films don’t emphasize locations, rather
they try to exist within a larger environment.
Instead of INT.
Coffee Shop.
DAY.
We get open skies, flowing rivers, and vast
landscapes of skyscrapers.
And this environment is one that includes
animal life.
Malick’s inclusion of and focus on the animals
that incidentally surround his characters
is very unique in the narrative film world.
I think the inclusion of these seemingly irrelevant
details are a large part of what creates the
immediacy and subjectivity of the perspective.
In our lives, in the present, we often don’t
yet know which details are relevant to our
“story.”
It’s only in hindsight that we can exclude
everything extraneous to the story we’d
like to tell.
Malick often handles what plot does exist
in a very loose sense.
Plot only exists in his films primarily as
an accessory to the character’s journey.
While Badlands is perhaps his most Plot heavy
film, we still catch a glimpse Malick’s
future work in how he treats the films plot.
One of those things is how He shows story
through montage.
Instead of a traditional scene structure,
we get sections where he uses a montage of
moments, along with music and voiceover.
He continues to expand his use of this technique
throughout his career, with some of his later
films existing almost entirely in this mode.
Besides a the change in cinematography, the
other change in Malick’s style that lead
to where he is now is in the editing.
It won’t be until The New World that we’ll
see the type of scenes that represent what
I think of as “classically” Malick.
But all the ingredients for scenes like that
one (Music, voiceover, and montage) are present
in his earlier films and Badlands.
It would just take a some additional experimentation
in the editing room to bring it to it’s
full form.
Finally in Badlands we can see Malick’s
preference for naturalistic lighting.
Badlands features many scenes shot during
“golden hour” the hours surrounding sunrise
and sunset.
He will go on to shoot some of his later films
almost entirely during this time of day.With
Badlands Malick showed an immediate competence
and grasp of more conventional filmmaking.
His career since then has become progressively
more experimental.
Like Wes Anderson the first director I talked
about in this series, Terrance Malick is a
great example of how small elements of director’s
style evolve into something more pronounced
and obvious throughout their career.
But also like Wes, we can see how the more
foundational elements of Malick’s style
were present even before the obvious visual
characteristics emerge.
This series is made possible by MUBI.
MUBI.com is a cinema streaming and download
service.
They have 30 movies streaming at a time, every
day one is added and one is taken away.
MUBI’s strength is in it’s curation, it
gets me to watch a lot of interesting stuff
that I never would have found otherwise.
If you’re a fan of Malick’s films, MUBI
will definitely have some things to watch
that are right up your alley.
I could keep trying to convince you why MUBI
is great, but you really have no excuse not
to find out for yourself, you can try MUBI
free for 30 days at M-U-B-I dot com, slash
Thomas Flight, that’s MUBI dot com slash
Thomas Flight for your extended free trial.